New Orleans' Mardi Gras is more than just a celebration before the Christian season of Lent begins.
In this city, preparations for the big day begin weeks and even months in advance.
Early mornings are nothing new for bakers.
But the pre - dawn workload grows during Carnival season.
From January 6 through Fat Tuesday,...
...New Orleans' Cake Cafe and Bakery is a beehive of activity,...
...where they make as many as 50 King Cakes a day.
Here, they make non - traditional goat cheese and apple stuffed cakes.
There's very old-school King Cakes in New Orleans;...
...they've been at it for 50, 60, 100 years some of them.
And they have a loyal following.
The old-school King Cake has a tiny baby or other trinket baked inside.
And whoever gets the trinket has obligations,...
...such as buying next year's King Cake.
Here, the baby goes on the outside.
The King Cake is a traditional New Orleans Mardi Gras pastry.
You'll find pastries like this all over the country and all over the world,...
...that they're only served for a certain season during the year.
In another part of town, Sally Hedrick and her son are making 150 or more ornate costumes.
These are for the social organizations throwing the lavish balls and parades.
Some may go for more than $3,000.
It's rewarding to see the women in these costumes gleam,...
...but it's more rewarding to see the men...
...because a man didn't get to dress up in beautiful clothes.
He's usually in a tuxedo.
Hedrick works on costumes year-round,...
...refurbishing ones that took a bit of a beating during last year's Mardi Gras celebrations...
...and creating new works.